Alright. In this lecture we're going to
talk about linear models. Now in linear
models what you do is you see that there's
some, independent variable. X. And this is
a variable that, that, could be anything.
It could be hours spent exercising. It
could be money spent on advertising. It
could be anything that you want. And then
you assume that there's some other
variable. Y. Dead is a function of X. So
if X is hours spent exercising Y could be
life expectancy. If X is amount of money
you spend on advertising then Y can be
sells. Now what we do is we assume there
is a particular relationship between Y and
X that it's not any old function. In fact
what we do is we assume it's a simple
line. So here's X, here's Y. We assume
that we can write Y= MX + B. That Y is
just a linear function. X. So formally
right, you see the [inaudible] typical
graph and y on this axis and here is X. B
is the intercept. So this is representing
Y equals M X plus B. If X equals zero, B
is the value that Y will take. And then M
right is gives the slope. So tells u sort
of how fast is it's going up. How fast
this thing is going up. You can move or
you can increase X by one. How much does Y
get increased? Now remember I talked about
the difference between a linear model and
a line. So, in a line, we just have that
equation, Y=MX+B. In a linear model, what
we're assuming is that there's some
independent variable X, there's some
dependent variable Y. And Y depends on X,
or assuming that X somehow causes Y to
occur. All right. Let's do an example,
simple example. Suppose you think about
buying a TV, and you want to know, how
much is that TV gonna cost? So I wanna
construct a linear model of the cost of
the TV. So let's let x be the length of
the diagonal, right? So you get your
square screen, right? And then TVs are
measured by the diagonal. That way they
can pretend the TV's bigger than it really
is. 'Kay, so x is the length of the
diagonal. Y is the cost of the TV and
suppose you say here is my linear model. I
think the cost is fifteen times the length
in inches. Plus a $100. So you put a
dollar sign here, to show this is a
hundred dollars. That could be the model
of what it costs for a TV. Now there's two
things you wanna think about when you have
these two linear models. First is the sign
of that coefficient. So, if I have y
equals 5x. Right, that five is positive
that's says y is increasing an x. So in
the case of the TV, we expect the price of
the TV to go up as it gets bigger. So
expect the sign to be positive. Second
thing we care about is the magnitude. How
big is that coefficient? So how much does
the price go up every time you make X
figure by one? So when you think about
using these in policy settings, right? So
suppose you know that school lunches
[inaudible] school lunches improve
performance. Well, the sign on that would
be, well, is performance higher if people
get school lunches, right? So is there a
positive coefficient? So why do we
construct models, right? Bunch of reasons,
one though is to predict, right? Another
is to understand data. So let's talk about
just using this simple model to try and
predict. So supposed you're thinking
about, wonder what it cost to buy a 30
inch TV, what we can, is we can plug it
in. And so the cost would be fifteen.
Times the diagonal. Plus 100. So what that
would be is 450. Plus 100, which should be
$550. So that would say if I want to go
buy a 30-inch TV, it's gonna cost me $550.
And so if that's, if we had a good model,
this would be what a TV costs, if we had a
bad model, this would be way off base. But
let's suppose this is your model, and I
think you can use it, you can use it to
predict things that maybe don't even
exist. So suppose you think, what if they
made a 100-inch TV, how much would that
cost? Well, if you assume this same
relationship holds, you could just say,
well, I'm gonna say, the cost should be
fifteen. Times a 100, plus a 100. Which is
gonna be 1,600. So we can make, 100
[inaudible] will be $1,600 [laugh] okay
so. Maybe wanna sit around and wait for
that 100 [inaudible] to come around. Or
maybe $1,600 is too rich for your blood.
You're gonna say well you know what. I'm
happy with the 30 incher. Okay, and again
what you can use this model for is to
predict. Now the model might not be
accurate, right because the world may not
be linear. But as a benchmark, this isn't
really a bad thing to do. Now also
understanding data rate. There's all these
data here, right. These are all these
dots.1 Thing you can do is with your model
rate is you can. Think okay, how well can
I fit a line through there? Now let's go
back to our last lecture from, remember in
our last lecture we talked about R
squared, how much of the variation can you
explain. Well there's a lot of variation
in this data. Well you can do the same
thing with a line. You can ask, how far is
this data line from my line? Right? And so
how much of that total variation I
explained by just that drawing that line
through there. So you can do the same
exact thing that you do for the
categories, for the lines, and that's
we're actually gonna do in the next
lecture. But for now, I just wanna get
across this idea that you can use a linear
model to try and make sense of a data like
this and also to make predictions. Here's
the thing. Remember I said, first lecture,
that models are better than we are. Well
let me support that even with these simple
models. So Robyn Dawes, who?s at Carnegie
Mellon, in 1979, wrote a paper comparing
very, very primitive linear models. So,
all he worried about is sorta getting the
coefficient close to right. So, for
example, here's one case, he had 43 bank
loan officers and they're trying to
predict whether. These firms were gonna go
belly up or not, because they'd repay
their loans. And so they were given 60
loans, 30 of which they, it was already
known had failed, and 30 if which was
already known had succeeded. And they
asked these people to predict what was
gonna happen. Now, these bankers, they're
pretty smart. They were 75 percent
accurate, so that's actually pretty good.
But if you took a simple linear model,
just based on that ratio of assets to
liabilities of the people taking out the
loans. That was right 80 percent of the
time. So the models beat the people. That,
say fine, that's one example. This has
been studied in detail right. So in 1954,
[inaudible] did a study, twenty studies of
clinicians, so these are doctors, right,
making predictions versus just doing a
simple linear model. And Sawyer in 1966
did 45 studies of predictions out there in
the social world. All 65 of these studies
it is never, never the case that the
experts did significantly better than the
linear models. So there's cases where they
were close, right where the expert?s maybe
a little better but it wasn't
significantly better. And there were a ton
of cases where the linear models did
better. So if you do a horse race, right.
Linear models tend to be better than
experts. Remember we saw this, this is
that tetlock, this is the graph from
tetlock again. Here's formal models way up
here- Right? And, this is, again, this is
measuring how [inaudible] how good those
models are at explaining variation. What
you get is that formal models are better
than people are. Now again, you don't
wanna only rely on the formal model. What
you'd like to do is, do the linear model.
And compare that linear model to your own
judgment. Okay, so what have we done? What
we've done is we've shown that you can
draw a line through data and use that line
to explain some of the variation in the
data. Now typically the world isn't gonna
be perfectly linear. There's going to be
lots of extra variation left over, but
there's a question of how much of that
variation did the line explain. In
addition to explaining the variation, the
line tells us something about the
relationship between our independent
variable, x and our dependent variable, y.
In particular, we learn the sine on x,
like does y increase in x or decrease in
x, and we also learn something about the
magnitude, so how much does. Each one unit
increase of x increased the value of y. So
what this linear model can do is help us
understand something about data we see in
the real world. Now what we've done so far
though, right, is just consider a single
variable linear model, right? So y was
just a function of x. Where we're gonna go
next is to think of y depending on a whole
bunch of different x's. So you can think
of your outcome having a whole bunch of
different variables that contribute to it,
and we'll start out by seeing how each of
those variables contribute in a linear
way. Okay, thank you.